is this your holding here sir it's a
marine toad cone and really you should
probably be holding on to it and get
used to this what okay should I just
look at the face on this guy is it okay
to hold him is he dangerous at all well
no he's not dangerous it's an
interesting creature it might get him a
little bit closer up to the shoulders
they're giving a little like shoulder
support okay all right I'm not a frog
bra what are you talking about here we
go these are among the largest uh frogs
in the world this is a toad uh this one
weighs about three pounds I've collected
a toad in Africa or actually a frog in
Africa that weighs twice as much twice
as much as this one it's about a yard
long with its legs extended but this is
still a pretty you know Hefty nice tote
where is the other thing chicken under
the chin they like that uh yeah the the
main thing about these toads is that
they're uh
hallucinate
their hair what do you mean they're
hallucinogenic uh uh people have
actually been arrested for possessing a
toad with the intent to lick so do not
look like you want to lick this toad but
uh now you make me just want to do it
you've actually bite
this is a habit you don't want to lick
[Music]
very nice guy you can you can actually
die from licking this toad
why don't you bring that up now didn't
you see me move in for the lick and you
said nothing this is a nine banded
armadillo and if you counted those bands
they're probably more than nine they can
have as many as 11 right I'm gonna turn
them around this one how do they get
extra bands is it like the Cub Scouts
where you move your way up the ladder
work is as they get older and the bands
basically allow them to kind of kind of
curl up a little bit this species of
armadillo he doesn't look yeah he looks
very
right now we're having everything about
this armadillo is like I'll go on the
show but I'm not gonna like it
this protects that animal from predators
like coyotes or even you know big cats
like mountain lions will have a hard
time getting through that and of course
this is the only other species out there
that can get leprosy and so sometimes it
does
you don't have to worry this guy does
not have leprosy I promise
you know it's the timing of your
information
it's really the great part here why
don't you lick that all up
it's the old leprosy cat
you're perfect you're just like his
perch
I why don't we he's wondering who's got
the weirder hairstyle
he's like ah impressive
is he good he's checking out your hair
though
I'm gonna let you feed him that Walnut
and the reason for that is that check
out the massive
whoa okay and that's a powerful jar
right yes I was just gonna say check out
that massive beak on this bird this this
it's kind of parrot it's it's a black
palm cockatoo native to Australia parts
of Southeast Asia that giant bill is
designed to do what it's doing right now
which is which is crushed nuts and they
can take Palm nuts which are super super
hard
and exert 1500 pounds of pressure with
that beat and just straight through that
sounds
sorry didn't mean it didn't mean it it's
cool you just keep doing it look how
delicate he is with the tongue yeah you
know and that's getting the nut out of
there and they use that tongue it's
almost like like a finger and this this
species bill is so big that beak is so
big that they actually can't even shut
their mouth completely so that tongue
kind of almost works in the same way
that you know like your thumb would work
and if you can see that that's exactly
what he's doing he's reaching in and
he's actually able to pull that Walnut
right out of that shell just with his
tongue it's pretty fascinating
incredible uh this is a very strange
experience
but I'm very calm and he seems calm he
is he is and you know he likes you
because his Crest is is totally up
um
yeah
six month old Bobcat maybe one of the
toughest cats we have in North America
is it okay if I pet this cat absolutely
she's loving it super athletic these
cats will actually use this camouflage
but all these spots are get down on the
grass right wait for birds to fly over
and leap 10 feet in the air and snag
them out there and have them for lunch
these cats live right in Los Angeles
people don't even know they're in their
backyard I mean there's camouflage
they're super elusive whoa look at that
finally had enough and put an end to it
love that finally had enough and
destroyed it uh really a beautiful
animal you know who else hates this Andy
look at this
athletic
the Bobcats like I respect you brother
I'm going to step over here Conan if you
just want to stay behind me yeah I'll
stay behind you
this is a Nile crocodile okay do we want
to let that thing go
she'll be okay once we get her oh she'll
be fine it's us I'm worried about so
see this is even as a juvenile this is
only about a five foot animal this is a
species that can get to be that this
animal can get to be 15 to even 20 feet
long and
you know they're crocodiles most people
know their crocodiles are you know
tremendous Predators when they get to
their full growth they're actually able
to take down you know animals as big as
zebras so look at that hate staring
she's just gonna hang out there
it's just like you son of a
you can get her to show those teeth
loaned you twenty dollars four years ago
yeah
I don't think she's gonna work work for
us you know she's not going to open up
her mouth too big there well she looks
really mad so the whole poking it with a
stick thing
with a stick if you look at the fourth
tooth
down yeah get in there with your finger
and show me yeah no I'm not going to do
that that fourth I can't tell I need to
see specifically which sticks up from
the bottom there that's one one really
good way to tell alligators or
crocodiles alligators are also kind of
like a dark blackish color and they have
a big wide fat head and they're actually
a lot more chill than crocodiles are and
she for a crocodile is actually doing
really well she's she's almost just kind
of going into a little trance there but
uh but crocodiles they attitude if you
don't really want a little bit of a trip
to them but I'd hate to see this thing
when it's in a trance
it is so stoned right now look at it oh
man he's just thinking about the late
60s
crazy stuff went down on the Nile
yeah beautiful eyes
amazing
[Applause]
did you see that look
like the eyes are so big they have to
spin their heads to see it spun it said
360 degrees there does he uh oh look at
that they're made of all feather yeah my
finger just keeps going this is uh two
eyeballs on some feathers there's no
there's nothing in here yeah the
feathers are so soft so they fly so I
don't they foreign
[Applause]
excuse me oh my God is this what i is
this this is these guys are both bear
cubs oh my God so you you have a brown
bear cup that's a European brown bear
and this is a North American oh God this
is the greatest thing I've ever seen
they are adorable and I have children I
love this
I have two children and I love this bear
more than much
well I'll tell you what you you love it
now but when these guys get big again
these are not animals that regular
people can have as pets even though
believe it or not some people try do you
want to hold them they're not regular
people we're on TV yeah coyote pup all
right
can I uh can I have that you can hold it
no I want to have it no you can't have
it these are why can't I have it people
think these are guys are good good pets
they're terrible pets because what you
want to do is support
perfect
These Guys these guys are actually
taking in as pets a lot and they're bad
pets today this is my uh Tiger Beat
photo spread uh
I didn't realize I was going to bring
all these animals for us to rub our
faces and heads up against
[Applause]
same kind of coyote that you would see
all around here in California the types
of uh the guys that are sort of in the
in the Wild Spaces up here
um now this is you know what I really
connect with this coyote
I raised this coyote would it eventually
do my bidding you know I don't know if
they're doing your bidding you know the
problem with it is these guys are
somewhat solitary mostly solitary so
they're not used to like being a pack
like a dog or a wolf so the bond
wouldn't be as tight as it would be if
you raised it to raise a wolf when he
got he became an adult he'd be dangerous
to me you know he'd be skittish and if
you scared him he'd bite you know it's
funny these guys have got a real bad rap
around California because
they do go after like the small dogs I
don't know what I'm doing right now I
don't
I don't think coyote knows what you're
doing right now I'm just licking him
yeah well if you know his mom or dad
would be licking him so at this age
that's what my wife does she's like oh
no
actually the first time that I've worked
with this particular species it's called
an uh an African Southern ground
hornbill and he's taking his time coming
in
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I love that he took one Peak and he was
like I think not
well come on it's a fun show don't go by
what you've read
this is the biggest venomous snake
species on Earth okay and I need your
help can you why do you want my help I
need you to use that as a Target please
[Music]
nothing distracts a snake like a baby
head yeah
you've got to keep it moving keep its
attention why why do we have to keep its
attention well they're very good visual
Predators it can't hear but it's using
me to do distract the deadly snake is
that right so this is a king cobra okay
and what would happen if this thing were
to bite somebody you can it's got enough
Venom to kill
an elephant
and then look okay
there we go
advancing towards me you idiot
[Music]
these can grow to 18 feet long and be
careful it doesn't and it's natural
predator is a baby on a stick is that
the idea
beautifully there we go look and if I
can wrestle oh
quickly no we don't want that I'll save
you oh
okay uh how do we make this segment stop
put him down here
there we go and around we go
[Applause]
if I sort of
get them like this
do you want me to turn the trash can the
other way around why are you going under
there after it
okay here that's good I think if I can
oh
sorry it's going a bit this way oh no
we've got that in the front the crowds
that's fine no it's not doing it it's
fine sir please terrific they're away
for the baby again yeah that's no no put
it back
oh that's weird
stop my Hook's stuck there we go okay
come on fella you're the animal expert
three times in a segment you've gone
like this
no come on you gotta move
that's a lemur yeah and you know what
Conan I'm actually just he likes to go
up to tall things and you're much bigger
than I am so let's do that
you can just let him crawl all around
just take your arms what is butt in my
face
hey buddy come on
good job I feel like the lamest
superhero right now
with control of his lemur
away
what you're doing right now is actually
just simulating where these guys live
they're arboreal that means they live in
the trees these are our primates so
they're kind of related to monkeys they
live only on the island of Madagascar
and they're super endangered all right
his um his little jelly treat here kind
of flopped out there so let's see let's
see what he does he's safe down to it do
you want me to lower myself yeah go
ahead and lower your arm and see what he
does okay every show you lower yourself
come on let's let's see if we can get
him over here
I think he won come here buddy let's see
I walked right into that